hey guys this is dennis defender think
here and i'm david griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of the Robocop movie the
reboot night the 2014 version 1987
version of verhoeven not Paul Verhoeven
I you know that one's a classic I really
like that movie this one's directed by
jose a-put he padilla yeah yeah if
there's no imagery yeah starring joel
kinnaman who i really like from the
killing hmm would you think of the movie
I actually I liked it um give you kind
of it's hard not to because the name it
is Robocop so you can't really distance
yourself from the the classic film but
this was fun I mean I like this better
than the GI Joe movies I thought it was
more straight for it was kind of stood
kind of your basic action movie I mean
like if you were sitting at home
watching tnt or something at like nine
o'clock at night this was on you can
just have popcorn just watch it like
it's nothing special or unique
necessarily about it but I really liked
I think a lot of it has to do with the
leading actor I thought he brought way
more emotion in a more relatability the
character than the original Robocop ever
do you watch The Killing yet I have not
seen the killing so this is my first
experience huh with this action I'm like
this guy is holding together the whole
movie I'm like he's good like I could
watch I would see a sequel with him in
it I like him even though the movies not
missing anything special I like to him
yeah you should watch The Killing he's
really good and he's like the co-lead
yeah and yeah for me the movie was ok
yeah it was ok there's parts that i
liked parts that i didn't hate the movie
you know like you know i came in with
lower expectations i'm not one of those
fanboys that are like oh my god they're
touching Robocop it's a classic you
shouldn't touch n type of stuff which i
think a lot of the hate that's coming
for this movie is from is like because
it's a totally different movie oh yeah
then yeah the 87 version that was a
satirical look right yeah you know it's
a lot of humor a lot of like
over-the-top stuff this one is a it's an
action movie basically it's a heron
sci-fi movie that tries to put a little
hard and it tries to put a little social
and political commentary in there but it
doesn't exactly execute everything you
know yeah as well as movies that even
though the cast is impressed
no Gary old man and his name Michael
Ealy from watchmen high seas name Oh
Jackie Earle Haley Haley from watchmen
and like okay yeah he's good Michael
Keaton was I thought fine but the kind
of like they're all kind of dialing in
their performances it's cept for the
lead I thought he liked you could tell
that he believed in the film I really
thought that when I was watching like
this guy like wants this to be good I
mean the material is it enough for him
to work with I don't think of I'm
assuming the killing has much better
material beyond the area but I could
tell that of all the actors I thought he
was really trying the hardest to make it
a good Phil I I thought like I said he
made the movie for me if I think if he
wasn't in it I don't know if I would
have liked to the ball but I kind of
liked it yeah I actually like for me it
was the first half i enjoyed and enjoyed
what they were setting up with it and
then I kind of kind of fell a little
part for me in the second half because
then it turned into the standard action
yeah everyone's corrupt and everyone's a
villain and you know that type of stuff
where I thought like for me the best
scene was between Gary Oldman who played
the doctor dr. Norton and you'll
kinnaman who was playing Alex Murphy /
no cop in the scene where Alex Murphy
you know I don't want to spoil it but
Alex Murphy sees who he is now yeah he's
not just like bubble you know I mean
he's he's way more emotion yeah so that
scene between him and Gary cuz you could
see that Gary Oldman was his character
was empathetic towards you know towards
him it wasn't just Alex Murphy wasn't
just like a test subject to him right no
um Gary Oldman you have kind of plays
the the doctor who was ambitious but yet
he's a good guy you know like he means
well but he's caught up in this big
corporate world but like you know this
isn't a splitter be like a seam in the
very beginning like you know helping
this guy with artificial hands and how
to play the guitar which is really are
remember how to play it would be really
cool scene but then he gets stea nope
tone in the Robocop program and you know
he's gotta answer Michael keys like a
corrupt Steve Jobs you know he's like
he's kind of hip and slick you know
because I don't know he's got it might
be a Steve Jobs like I think I think
they would have done better if they
played Michael Keaton
not up is like a villain you know more
just a businessman right and and that he
just wants you know he's like obsessed
with with having all the his technology
and all across America versus you know
the the mustache twirling villain type
of thing right and then I mean you also
have heavy corn issues as the wife who's
always she's solid I never quite by her
but I mean I think she did a good job I
think again the material isn't great and
really you know she didn't have
something like her to do is that be like
the crying like where's my husband
where's my husband it's not her fault
it's not that we're gonna have more
right of that cuz that's what I heard I
heard oh yeah this one is more hardened
it's more about his family and yeah they
have them but they're not really there
they're like kind of part of the story
but they mention them a lot they're
actually not you know yeah present and I
thought this is a movie that like the
cast is there you have all the pieces
are there it's just the plot you know I
like it kind of jumped tml Jackson he's
funny but I felt like I'm like he's
probably in some studio in la na thi
guarantees not even on set he was never
day on safe driving la playing golf like
a couple hours a day going and doing
some lines and going home like he didn't
need anybody he probably did in a day or
two Yeah right on like a green screen
exactly he didn't need to be and I mean
he's funny like Samuel Jackson but it's
just well that's where it's weird
because the tone cuz obviously the first
robocop is a satire so there's a lot of
humorous elements to it they don't
almost very prophetic cuz we need a
Detroit I mean look at Detroit now
Detroit I mean is in its was in freefall
then but I mean Detroit is still
struggling I mean that was like a movie
looking at that too now it's like they
almost kind of went away from all that
stuff with Detroit and yeah well I mean
they also have over-the-top violence and
the first one that was rated or I was
just PG that money can make that money
uh but that it's weird because this one
has different tones in it does have
funny elements in it and they try to put
a little satire in it from times that's
where Sam Jackson's character from brave
and they sprinkle elements but it's not
a full-on satire like robocopy right and
this one they
you the action thing they try to do the
sci-fi thing try to do the drama that
very safe yeah and so it's not it
doesn't fully gel together well I mean I
like the production design like the suit
I love his bike the bike he was driving
around the bike was cool I wish they had
kept him silver the whole time yeah I
really care for the black suit you lose
a lot of detail in the black suit right
in the in the silver one you see the
parts reacting when it's all black it
just ends up looking like just mush
right right and I don't is maybe last
movie we see of this Clemmy I don't with
lego movie doing so well this we don't
know how Robocop's going to do will you
know what we'll see how it does
hopefully does well I mean I again I
like the lead i like the the cast but
this thing needs to be given something a
little bit bad a little better material
okay we're your overall thoughts in
grade i give it a be you know i give it
a be i think it's if you if you can take
away the title from which ago that comes
from and just like watch is like it's a
kind of a solid action flick i think
it's be that's a good action movie okay
so even have be- mhm I mean there's some
stuff there but ultimately it's not a
must see right now it's not like lego
movie like where you have to go see it
all right it definitely was probably a
solid rental yeah a good run out i'll
read on resolving rental yeah don't have
to see it in the few years and though if
you you are interested seeing it on the
big screen with action in the sound that
may be something you can't get at home
but i wouldn't say that you have to see
it yeah I mean we saw in imax you know
it's just huge you know sound but yeah
it's not you don't have to rush the
theaters to go see go see the lego movie
instead alright guys so that's what we
thought of Robocop the rebooted version
pote you can post your comments below on
the website think you're calm or on
YouTube think hero pro make sure to
subscribe to that we're going to check
us out on Twitter come chat with us
Dennis and I let us know we thought a
Robocop or your thing about going to see
it or if you even saw the original you
know some who are younger out there so I
haven't seen the original that's that
thing hero i'm at griffin d and we also
have a Facebook page that's facebook.com
slash think hero fans and make sure you
like that page and share our videos on
social media